I had a great time guys I'm gonna miss
you all for the first couple of days you
kept saying you can't fix ugly and it
broke you all have fixed ugly the Queer
Eye Community is more the death of Tom
Jackson who appeared in the Netflix
reboots 2018 pilot episode you can't fix
ugly he was 63 years old
the show's official Instagram account
shared the sad news on Wednesday
alongside snaps of Tom on the show
writing it's with a heavy heart that we
say goodbye to a member of our queer eye
family rest in peace Tom Jackson did you
ever think you'd have a bunch of gay men
blindfolding you and telling you
somewhere
we called this 50 Shades of gay film
Fifty Shades again you ready for it oh
God I'm ready tan France commented on
the post writing such incredibly sad
news Jonathan van s wrote R.I.P Tom
while Bobby Burke said he's having a
redneck margarita in Tom's honor do you
all want a redneck Margarita I actually
would try one I would try one
tequila and Mountain Dew that actually
sounds really good who doesn't love
Margaritas who doesn't love Mountain Dew
who doesn't like tequila
according to Tom's obituary he lost his
battle with metastatic adenocarcinoma a
type of cancer on March 3rd as for his
appearance on the show Tom's obituary
called it a highlight of his life we
have fallen in love with you and I
didn't really expect to have this moment
with you and you were such an amazing
man
no it's okay hey Tom you're such a good
man he enjoyed the notoriety and shared
his experience with whoever would listen
during the 2018 episode Tom rekindled
his romance with his ex-wife Abby Parr I
love Abby more than anything I want to
spend the rest of my life with her the
two remarried in 2018 though they
separated in 2019 according to his
Twitter would you like to do this again
something I would love that would you
like to go to dinner with me next
Saturday night he's asking for dinner
today
yes I would love to
yes Tom's obit asked that family friends
and fans watch season one episode one of
queer eye and tell others about it in
Tom's honor we'll miss all of you guys
cheers
this
[Music]
is